génération identitaire c'est ça un col
de montagne occupé en 2018 pour empêcher
les migrants de passer est possible de
reprendre le cours de nos frontières
un bar identitaire à lille en 2016 avec
un accès prévenu la base oui et ses
méthodes de race blanche génération
identitaire un groupuscule d'ultra
droite il s'illustre lors d'actions
contre les migrants contre l'islam pour
la race blanche
il est l'héritier d'un autre mouvement
au même thématique disparu en 2002 voici
le groupuscule unité radicale
cette organisation extrémiste est
dissoute par le gouvernement en 2002
décision prise après une tentative
d'assassinât contre le président jacques
chirac par un proche de la mouvance
unité radicale a pris du poil de la bête
le groupe profite de cette médiatisation
inespéré pour diffuser son idéologie
radicale l'unité radicale n'est plus
mais le combat des militants n'est pas
terminée
là on aurait zone au contact de
responsables donc dans quelques semaines
un nouveau mouvement d'art y apparaître
fabrice robert l'une des têtes pensantes
d'unité radicale exécute sa promesse il
fonde en 2002 le bloc identitaire qu'il
préside encore aujourd'hui leurs
méthodes sont radicales en 2004 par
exemple ils prennent d'assaut une église
à saint denis dont le prêtre apporté son
soutien à des sans papiers
je me suis trouvée
le visage rempli de mousse arrachée
bombe lacrymogène d'encre je ne sais pas
quoi halte à l'immigration à l'islam
préservation de la race blanche et
chrétienne
le credo reste le même l'implantation
national du bloc identitaire est faible
il s'en crée néanmoins dans le sud de la
france finit sa toyota bastion ou même
pour toute la mouvance nationaliste 1
depuis des décennies
c'est vrai que nous avons un groupe
assez important ici en 2012 dix ans
après sa création le bloc identitaire
revendique 2000 adhérents
c'est alors que se constituent la frange
jeunesse du groupuscule baptisé
génération identitaire elle s'illustre
immédiatement avec l'occupation du toit
d'une mosquée à poitiers en 2016 la
section génération identitaire prend son
envol et devient autonome avec ses
propres leaders
le groupe revendique 3000 membres il ne
serait en fait pas plus de mille selon
les spécialistes
[Musique]